okay well so so that's another issue in
some sense that seems to make the
postmodernist critique even more correct
how in the world you're going to extract
out a canonical interpretation of
something like that it's like it's not
possible but here's the issue as far as
I can tell the interpret so the post
modernists extended that critique to the
world they said look while a text is
complicated enough you can't extract out
a canonical interpretation what about
the world the world's way more
complicated than a text and so there's
an infinite number of ways that you can
look at the world and so how do we know
that any one way is better than any
other way that's a good question now the
postmodern answer was we can't and
that's not a good answer because you
drown in chaos under those circumstances
right you can't make sense of anything
and that's not good because it's not
neutral to not make sense of things
it's very anxiety-provoking it's very
depressing because if things are so
chaotic that you can't get a handle on
them your body defaults into emergency
preparation mode and your heart rate
goes up and your immune system stops
working and like you burn yourself out
you AIDS rapidly because you're
surrounded by nothing you can control
varying that's an existential crisis
right it's anxiety provoking and
depressing very hard on people and even
more than that it turns out that the way
that we're constructed
neurophysiological E is that we don't
experience any positive emotion unless
we have a name and we can see ourselves
progressing towards that Abe it isn't
precisely attaining the aim that makes
us happy as you all know if you've ever
attained anything because soon as you
attain it then the whole little game
ends and you have to come up with
another game right so it's it's civis
and now that's okay but but it does show
that the attainment can't be the thing
that drives you because it collapses the
game that's what happens when you
graduate from university it's like
you're king of the mountain for one day
and then you're like surf fest at
Starbucks for the next five years and
home so
yeah so what happens is let that human
beings are weird creatures because we're
much more activated by having an aim and
moving towards it than we are by
attainment and what that means is you
have to have a name and that means you
have to have an interpretation and it
also means that the nobler they aim
that's one way of thinking about it the
better your life and that's a really
interesting thing to know because you
know you've heard ever since you were
tiny that you should act like a good
person you shouldn't live for example
and you might think well why the hell
should I act like a good person and why
not live I mean even a three-year-old
can ask that question because smart
smart kids learn to lie earlier by the
way and they think well why not twist
the fabric of reality so that it serves
your specific short-term needs I mean
that's a great question why not do that
why act morally if you can get away with
something and it brings you closer to
something you want well why not do it
these are good questions it's not
self-evident well it seems to me tied in
with what I just mentioned it's like you
destabilize yourself and things become
chaotic that's not good and if you don't
have a noble aim then you have nothing
but but shallow trivial pleasures and
they don't sustain you and that's not
good because because life is so
difficult so much it's so much suffering
it's so complex it ends and everyone
dies and it's painful it's like without
a no blame how can you withstand any of
that you can't you become desperate and
once you become desperate thing is gold
things go from bad to worse very rapidly
when you become desperate and so there's
the idea of the noble aim and it's not
something it's something that's
necessary it's the bread that people
cannot live without right that's not
physical bread it's the noble aim and
what is that well it was encapsulated in
part of the story of Marduk that's tough
it's to pay attention it's to speak
properly it's to confront chaos it's to
make a better world it's something like
that and that's enough of the noble aim
so that you can stand up without you
know cringing at the very thought of
your own existence so that you can do
something that's worthwhile to justify
your wretched
position on the planet so you know
there's a the literary issue is that so
look you take a text you can interpret
in a variety of ways but that's not
right this is where the postmodernist
went wrong because what you're looking
for
in a text and in the world for that
matter is is sufficient order and
direction so then we have to think well
what is sufficient order and direction
means well you don't want to suffer so
much that your life is unbearable right
that just seems self-evident pain argues
for itself I think of pain as the
fundamental reality because no one
disputes it right I mean even if you say
that you don't believe in pain it
doesn't help when you're in pain you
still believe in it right it's you can't
pry it up with logic and rationality it
just stands forth as as what the
fundamental existence and that's
actually quite useful to know say well
you don't want any more of that than is
absolutely necessary and I think that's
self-evident and then you say wait a
minutes more complicated than that you
don't want any more of that that's
necessary today but also not tomorrow
and not next week and not next month and
not next year so however you act now
better not compromise how you're going
to be in a year because I'll just be
counterproductive that's part of the
problem with short-term pleasures right
it's like active haste repent at leisure
everyone knows exactly what that means
so you have to act in a way that works
now a.m. tomorrow and next week and next
month and so forth and so you have to
take your future self into account and
human beings can do that and taking your
future self into account isn't much
different than taking other people into
account right because I remember there's
this Simpson episode and Homer downs a
quart of mayonnaise and vodka
he says someone Marge says you know you
shouldn't really do that and Homer says
that's a problem for future Homer I just
I'm sure glad I'm not that guy